I can honestly tell you right now I have
never prepared this much for one review
in my life act of valor now I said on my
opening I never really prepared this
much for review and I mean it usually
when I get home from a movie I think
about the film a little bit and then I
review it I actually slept on this and
the next day I spent most of the morning
trying to figure out how to express
myself about this film this is a film
that uses real active duty Navy SEALs to
depict how they approach a situation to
depict various missions to show how they
go through their battles their strategy
the things that do to sacrifice
themselves for each other how they
protect their teammates how they help
others and it's really supposed to honor
and show the sacrifices they make in a
dignified way there's a few actors that
are recognizable throughout the film
namely Rosalyn Sanchez but the names of
the Navy SEALs who are acting the film
are not revealed now before I get into
my review I just want to say that I have
utmost respect for men who are willing
to lay down their lives and sacrifice
themselves for people they love and in
no way does my review reflect disrespect
for those men or the sacrifices they
made my grandparents survived World War
two my dad was in the Vietnam War and I
have friends who were at war right now
that being said this is a movie and this
is written by the writer of 300 and so I
feel that I must talk about it a little
bit yes basically these directors made a
short film about the Navy SEALs it was
well received and so they decided to
make a big film and they got a big
budget to be able to make a larger
actual feature they got the writer of
300 to write the script and now we have
a movie called active valor and you may
have heard this from other people and
it's true the acting in the film is
absolutely awful it's really some of the
worst acting I've seen and you can't
blame these men for doing that because
they aren't actors when the men are in
the field and they're in action and
they're doing what they do best it's
very well done and it feels very
realistic and less Hollywood eyes than
your average war film however the film
is not nonstop action there are a lot of
dialogue scenes and these scenes are a
little hard to watch and it's not just
because of the bad acting the script is
honestly awful the script is terrible
and as I said this is in no way
disrespecting the men who are making
these sacrifices but this is a guy who
sat down
this movie from a moviemaking
perspective the best set-piece in the
film is a jungle rescue in which they
are trying to rescue a hostage I really
liked that scene it was very well done
it felt real it felt it felt gritty it
felt like yes this is like a real
location these are men who know what
they do but then a very cliched
terrorist plot started to form in which
a guy with a big beard couldn't they
have picked someone to depict the
terrorists besides someone who looked
like the cliche terrorists that all
Americans just think every terrorist
looks like there are long and drawn-out
scenes of dialogue between this
terrorist organization where they
actually use real actors you can't
really sense a feel of a real story in
this movie I bet that this film worked
really well as a short film depicting
what Navy SEALs go through when they're
in the field if you truly want to honor
these men if you want to show them honor
if you want to respect what they do
making a two-hour commercial for the
Navy SEALs and making it look like Call
of Duty is not the way to do that I
honestly felt sorry for these guys
because seeing them in front of the
camera trying to read lines it just
really felt like they were out of their
comfort zone and I felt bad for him from
a directorial standpoint a filmmaking
standpoint it's nothing but cliches the
only soldier you really find out about
his family life is the one who has a
pregnant wife of course it's war movie
101 there's all these scenes where
soldiers just stop in slow motion and
look around at all of the carnage we've
seen this all before it's not depicted
in an interesting way and this is meant
to be no disrespect toward these men who
are really making these sacrifices in
real life but from a filmmaking
perspective the filmmakers and the
studio involved this movie dropped the
ball however if you're a war veteran
have someone at war if you are the
audience for this movie you will
appreciate it because you're not going
to go to this movie expecting a
well-told story and a movie that's
directed well you just want to see Navy
SEALs depicted the way they are and as
far as I've heard this film does that
very well and I'm not discounting that
at all but from a filmmaking perspective
this movie was very poorly made and I'm
going to have to give active valor a
c-minus so I'd like to know do you have
a favorite war related film my
personally is Saving Private Ryan but as
always if you'd like this review you can
subscribe to my channel get stuck mine
eyes